[MUSIC PLAYING]
DANNY HERMES: Hey, everybody.
I'm Danny Hermes.
Welcome to this week's edition
of App Engine Google
Developers Live.
I'm here to talk about endpoints
with my colleagues,
Dan Holevoet.
DAN HOLEVOET: Hi.
So today, we're going to talk
to you about a new feature
that has just reached the
experimental phase in the App
Engine SDK.
DANNY HERMES: Literally
just reached.
DAN HOLEVOET: Literally
hours before this.
And the basic idea behind this
feature called Google Cloud
Endpoints is that it's a really
easy way for you to
make APIs hosted on App Engine
that you can consume within
Android, iOS applications,
and JavaScript.
DANNY HERMES: Why would
you want to do that?
DAN HOLEVOET: Well, what we've
discovered with App Engine is
actually it's a really great
place to host back ends for
mobile applications.
So the big pitch behind this
feature is that you can
generate these APIs.
We provide really great tooling
around them so that
you can get great statically
typed client libraries for
Java and Objective C. And then
if you're building a mobile
application for the web as well,
you also get this great
JavaScript library.
DANNY HERMES: Totally.
All right, well, I'm going
to get started now.
From here forward, I'm going to
be teaching you guys about
Endpoints through live coding.
I'm going to be programming
in the Python SDK.
The Python App Engine SDK
version 1.7.5 just became
available today, and we had a
blog post announcing that.
So let's get started.
So here I am.
My application--
the very first thing I need,
I need an app.yaml file.
So I'm not going to actually
deploy anything today, we're
just going to be working in the
SDK, but everything that
works in the SDK is also going
to be working in production
and then some.
So my App ID, I'll just put
endpoints-app, just to be relevant.
We need a version, we
need a runtime.
I'm going to use python27.
Is it thread safe?
Threadsafe, true.
And I can't remember.
I've got to cheat.
API version, there we go, to
actually tell us which version
of the runtime were using.
And I'll just continue
cheating.
We're going to simply spin up a
back end, and we're going to
use some of the testing tools
provided with the SDK and some
of the rest of Google's API
tooling external to App Engine
to actually test
this back end.
We're not going to build a front
end, we're not going to
build JavaScript, iOS, or
Android clients, but we will
do this in the future.
We just want to show you
quickly, in a few minutes, how
you can get up and running
with your first back end.
So what I have here is I'm
mapping the path _ah/spi, and
then I have the wild card dot
glob, or dot asterisk after
that, meaning everything in that
path will be handled by
my app, main.application.
And this is a special internal
path used to actually talk to
Google's API infrastructure.
In this case, it's not directly
talking to our API
infrastructure because it's
running locally, but it talks
to an approximation of that.
But in production, it actually
talks to Google's API
infrastructure directly.
And I'll talk a bit more about
what that exchange looks like
when we write some code.
So now we need our main.py
file that's going to hold
application.
So I'll start up main.py.
I'm going to have to cheat a bit
on this, but I'm going to
go until I can't remember
anything.
So the first thing
we do, we need to
actually important endpoints.
So as of today, and actually as
of the last release but it
wasn't fully working, we
have App Engine in
google.appengine.ext, and
we can just import
endpoints from there.
And that provides us with most
of the things we need to
actually use endpoints.
There's one other import that's
pretty important, and
that's a library called
ProtoRPC.
So ProtoRPC, I'm going to take
a break and talk about it.
So we want the Messages module
within ProtoRPC, but what
ProtoRPC is, it's a library
that is an experimental
library as part of App Engine.
It was released several
months ago, maybe a
year ago at this point.
I'm not exactly sure of
the full timeline.
And it allows essentially a
native Python object that can
talk protocol buffers.
And this is pretty important,
especially when you're talking
Google's internal
infrastructure, to actually
send messages around and have
strongly typed messages
sending from one arbitrary
runtime to another.
And it's a way for large
services that aren't
necessarily the same to be able
to talk to each other.
And so since, as I mentioned
before, we have this path
_ahspi to actually talk to
Google's infrastructure, we
need to provide a mechanism
to actually make this
conversation happen.
And we use ProtoRPC to create
protocol buffers and actually
speak JSON RPC.
I'm not going to go much
further than that.
But essentially, it's a way to
have strongly typed messages
that you can use to actually
talk to other parts of the
infrastructure.
Cool.
So before we actually design
our application, I want to
talk about what it is.
So what I'm going to do is make
a simple API that allows
you to insert tasks and
to retrieve tasks.
Now, I know what you're
probably thinking.
Google has a Tasks API and we
saw Dan talk about it not too
long ago on GDL.
That's OK.
I'm not proposing that you build
a Task API, but it's a
simple enough concept for
everyone to understand, and I
just want to show you
a proof of concept.
But don't build a production
Task API, because you can
already use existing ones.
With that in mind, we need a
way to represent our tasks
using ProtoRPC, right?
So what kind of fields would
you like in a task object?
DAN HOLEVOET: Maybe a
name might be good.
DANNY HERMES: OK.
DAN HOLEVOET: Someone
who owns the task.
DANNY HERMES: OK.
DAN HOLEVOET: How about
a due date?
Can you do that one?
DANNY HERMES: Yeah.
Dan has made this difficult.
DAN HOLEVOET: Let's just start
with a name and an owner.
Can we do that one first?
DANNY HERMES: Yeah.
So the reason the due date is
difficult, it's just difficult
to do right.
We could fake it with a string,
but this is going to
leave the scope of this talk
pretty quickly if we do that.
So we're going to have the name,
which is a string, and
the owner--
again, just a string.
We're not going to use any Auth
to be able to find out
emails or names of people
inserting things.
So what we have here, we have a
class called Task, which is
going to represent our data,
and it's a subclass of
messages.message.
Messages is that module from
approach ProtoRPC, and this is
a ProtoRPC message definition
to actually
talk protocol buffers.
And so we give it two fields.
The first field is a name, and
this is going to be an
instance of
messages.StringField.
And we have these generic field
classes which actually
allow us to create classes
within our message classes,
like Task here.
And we actually have to give
them numbers to have some sort
of ordering within our protocol
buffer definition.
And for owner, I'm going to use
the same thing except I'm
going to give it the index
of two instead of one.
Now, should any of these
be required?
DAN HOLEVOET: The name should
probably be required.
DANNY HERMES: Name should
So we can add required equals
true to the string field that
represents name, and this will
actually be enforced when the
objects are created and passed
around and do other things.
Now, I'll just wrap up on
getting our data and actually
go and build the API.
So I need another class.
I need a class to represent
lists of tasks because we're
going to do queries that are
going to return lists.
So it's going to be the
same type of thing.
I'm not asking for Dan's
input on here.
We're just going to have one
field, Items, and then Items
Field is just going
to be a list.
So instead of Task, will
call it Task List.
Instead of Name, we'll
call the field Items.
It's not going to be
a string field.
It's actually going to
be a message field.
So this message field holds more
messages, and like we saw
with String Field, the very
first argument to the
constructor is the index.
For message fields,
it's actually the
class of the message.
So we need a list of tasks
in our task list.
So our message field is going
to have Task as the first
argument, the index one as the
second, and instead of
required, we're going to have
repeated equals true because
we'd like multiple tasks
within this task list.
OK, great.
So now we're representing
our data.
Now we need to actually
build our API.
And again, building the API,
we're going to use the
mechanics provided
by ProtoRPC.
I'm going to add from ProtoRPC,
import Remote here.
Remote is another module
provided by ProtoRPC which
allows for actually standing up
a ProtoRPC client which can
communicate externally.
These are just ways to represent
data, but Remote
actually allows us
to make a client.
And as we'll see, it allows us
to make a WSGI Handler, which
is what's going to end up in
application and be able to
talk to the rest
of the pieces.
OK, cool.
So we'll start off with a Task
API, is the silly name, and
it's going to be a subclass
of remote.Service.
And remote.Service is that
class that I was talking
about, that actually allows for
things like communication
and WSGI Handler, et cetera.
OK, great.
So we've got nothing in there.
We're going to need
two things, right?
We're going to need to
insert, and we're
going to need to list.
So I'm going to create two
dummy methods that
do nothing for now.
Insert is going to
start us off.
It's going to be an instance
method, meaning we have self
on it, and it's going
to take a request.
So the request is going to come
in and we're going to
insert something based on
what's in the request.
More details on that in a bit.
And then List is going to
be something similar.
I'm going to call
it List Tasks.
I could use List, but as we just
saw in Emacs there, it
recognizes it as one of those
reserves words in Python that
you probably just
shouldn't use.
And I'm also to be extra clear,
instead of insert, I'm
going to say insert
task, just to be
good programming citizens.
OK, great.
This is fine for now.
It won't actually matter.
So in order to make this talk
to Endpoints, we need to add
some decorators.
We need to annotate these a bit,
get some metadata, and
actually figure out what this
actually does, how it relates
to task list and task, which
we just defined, and a few
other bits and pieces.
So now, I'm actually going
to use this from
google.appengine.ext import
Endpoints import.
So what do you think the first
thing I should add is, Dan?
DAN HOLEVOET: I don't know.
Why don't you show us?
DANNY HERMES: Fine.
Dan doesn't like this.
Dan wants to talk about Java
endpoints, and I'm sure he
will at some point.
DAN HOLEVOET: I just don't want
to make it too difficult
for doing this on the air.
DANNY HERMES: I see.
He thought he made it
hard for me before.
Well, I kind of like it when I
screw up on camera because it
makes it more interesting for
you guys and lets you see how
we debug things and how we
actually program and figure
things out.
But Dan doesn't like
it, apparently.
DAN HOLEVOET: I want due
dates in a task.
DANNY HERMES: Yes.
So I'm going to first decorate
the service.
So this Task API service, it
needs to know its name.
For those of you who have used
Google APIs before, you'll
know for the majority of our
APIs, our discovery based
APIs, they're really
identified by
a name and a version.
So YouTube has three APIs.
The first two aren't discovery
based, but the third one is.
So if you have YouTube V3, you
can identify the YouTube API,
and so similarly for many
of our other APIs.
So we give it a name.
We'll just call it Tasks.
Very creative there.
We'll give it a version, V1.
And just for fun, I'm going to
give it a description so that
if any human was actually
consuming what's called the
discovery document for
this application--
I've already mentioned
discovery a bit--
they could see a nice
description of what this is.
So the human readable
description, we'll just say
API for task management.
It's not literally for task
management because we're not
to allow you to delete and check
off and do these other
things, but--
DAN HOLEVOET: Or
have due dates.
DANNY HERMES: --we
easily could.
Or have due dates.
Well, who needs a due date?
OK, great.
So now, I actually need
to do a similar
thing for the methods.
In the same way that the API
itself needs to know who it
is, each individual method
needs to know who it is
relative to the application.
So I'm going to do something
similar, but instead of
endpoints.API, I'm
going to use the
endpoints.method decorator.
Now, if these aren't intuitive
names, I don't know what else
we should have used.
I think they're pretty
intuitive names.
So we need to give this a few
things, but most importantly,
we need to tell it what kind
of data it can expect to
receive and what kind of data
it can expect to spit back
out, right?
So on the way in, we're going to
take a task, and on the way
out, we're going to spit
a task out, right?
It's not magic.
Now, what we do with that task
once it reaches our API is up
to us, but this is why we
actually made those protocol
buffer definitions, so that we
can actually figure out what's
supposed to go in here.
So we've got that.
This is the part where
I may need to cheat.
So I'm fairly certain I can
remember all this, but I guess
we'll try to run it and
see if it breaks.
That's the funnest thing.
So to give the method a name,
I'm actually going to use
task.insert.
I probably don't need to use the
dot, but I'm not 100% sure
if this will-- so traditionally
with Google
APIs, for those who are
familiar, we have an API, and
then there's sub-resources
within the API.
So for people familiar with the
Drive API, for example,
they have an About sub-resource,
and you can get
information about the
individual user as
it relates to Drive.
And they also have a File
sub-resource, so if you want
to get a list of files or get
metadata about an individual
file, delete a file, change a
title of a document, you name
it, they have a sub-resource.
So in this, we're thinking of
Task as our sub-resource and
Insert as the actual method
name for this.
In addition, we actually need to
tell the API the path that
it can expect the request
to come in on.
So here for Path I used
the string path.
I didn't mean to.
That's because I was
talking and typing.
We're just going to use
the string task.
So that means when they
come through--
in this case, it's going
to be _ah/API/task--
well actually, that's
not even sure.
There's more--
DAN HOLEVOET: API
name, version.
DANNY HERMES: Yeah,
/APIname/version/task, there we go.
They will actually
hit our API.
But you won't necessarily need
to worry about all this, as
we'll show in a bit, because
the rich amount of client
libraries that have been built
up by us and our colleagues
for people who are already
using Google APIs.
Within App Engine, we don't
necessarily talk about other
Google APIs as much, but other
teams that you may have seen
on GDL or through various other
things are very strongly
about building up this
ecosystem, making these
libraries work, and doing
great things like that.
DAN HOLEVOET: If you build an
API using Endpoints, the end
result will look a lot
like Google APIs that
were authored by Google.
And the way you consume them
within your applications will
feel very similar, if not
identical, to the way you'd
use other Google APIs.
DANNY HERMES: Definitely.
I believe I have everything
I need.
Actually, no, I don't quite.
So I'm also going to specify
an http method.
So I want to specify it as POST,
since we're inserting
something that's the
RESTful concept.
Now, I actually have
to know this.
POST is the default for this
keyword argument, but I wanted
to actually have it in there
to indicate it to you guys.
So enough talking.
I'm just going to actually wrap
up on this particular
method and we'll actually see
if we can get it to work.
So instead of actually saving
the request or doing anything
with it, we're just going to
return it back to the user and
see what happens.
So before I can run it, I
actually need an application.
I believe I can just use
endpoins.api_server and give
it a list of my APIs.
I haven't cheated yet, have I?
DAN HOLEVOET: Not really.
DANNY HERMES: I kind of took
the API version and then
mapped it to YAML.
So what I've done here, in
addition to endpoints.api and
endpoints.method, these
decorators that we've used, we
also have endpoints.api_server.
And what that does,
it takes a list of
APIs that you've defined--
so in this case, we've only
defined task API--
and it will actually spin up a
server to serve the request
and actually make
the API work.
So enough coding.
Let's actually see if
it works or not.
DAN HOLEVOET: Place your bets.
DANNY HERMES: Place your bets.
So I'm here in the Google
App Engine Launcher.
I haven't figured out how to
increase the font size on this
ever, but I've got my app
running, and I'll head over to
Chrome just to make
sure it's running.
So I went to the Admin
console for the app,
and again, it's running.
It's good.
And we want to test the actual
explorer for the application.
And so it's very simple.
There's a protected path under
_ah, which is, as people
familiar with App Engine know,
full of protected paths.
So if we go local host 8080,
which is the local name for
the app that I'm running,
_ah/api/explorer--
now, this is the moment
of truth.
Ha!
No problems.
No problems yet.
So what happened was, for people
who can't see, the font
size in the URL bar
is fairly small.
But what it's done is it's
redirected us to the Google
APIs Explorer, which lives
at developers.googl
e.com/APIs/explorer.
And it's passed the query
parameter base equals with the
actual place where my
application lives, and this
base is LocalHost8080/_ah/api.
And this is essentially a route
for all operations.
Dan mentioned that full path is
going to be this route plus
you API name plus your API
version plus whatever your
path is, right?
So this is how we're actually
calling it, and everything
gets constructed based on that
route and other pieces of data
by your application.
So it's loaded up the full
list of APIs that we have
available, just one.
When I constructed my
endpoints.api server, I just
passed it one thing.
That's all we expected.
We see the version, V1,
that we created.
Just to prove I'm not lying,
let's go change
it and refresh this.
Version vGDL.
Loading.
Wonderful!
No issues so far.
I don't know, maybe it's less
fun if there's no errors.
Maybe I should have had
more screw-ups.
DAN HOLEVOET: Maybe something's
secretly going to go wrong.
DANNY HERMES: Yeah, we'll see.
So we see the name we gave to
the API is Tasks, and then
this human readable description,
API for task
management, also there for your
use when you're debugging
and for end users if
you go that route.
So when I click into this API,
we get a list of the methods
that we have available to us.
So as I mentioned, we have the
task.insert method, and the
way it's interpreted by the
API's explorer and by the
general infrastructure that is
used to create these APIs,
Tasks is the API name, Task is
the resource, and Insert is
the method.
So I'm going to do something
which I hope breaks.
I'm going to try to call this
insert method with absolutely
nothing in there.
So we have this little box
with Request Body.
This is, again, part of the
phenomenal tooling we have
already available for you when
you're working with Google
APIs, can automatically
be used with your
API for testing out.
This Request Body knows
the fields that it has
available to it.
From the discovery document
for my application, we
actually see Name and Owner
here, which are the fields
that we added.
We made Name a required
property.
So I'm going to submit a request
without Name and see
what happens.
I'm going to guess that--
interesting.
Let's see what happens.
So we got a 400.
Wonderful.
And that 400 means it didn't
work, and the error is
essentially that there
was an error parsing
the ProtoRPC request.
So when ProtoRPC got the empty
body, it tried to turn the
empty body into an instance of
this task message class that
we defined, and it said,
no, no, no, no, no.
We're missing the required
field, Name.
DAN HOLEVOET: And does
it say that in there?
DANNY HERMES: It does.
DAN HOLEVOET: Excellent.
Message Task is missing
required field, Name.
That one is a bit ambiguous
if you call your field
"Name," it turns out.
DAN HOLEVOET: Give
it a better name.
DANNY HERMES: Let's
just give it Name.
Go to sleep.
That's a good name for
a task, right?
OK, wonderful.
So far, no bugs that
I know of.
So we have a 200, OK.
And the response is exactly
what was in the request.
So now, let's make the API do
something, something at all.
So we have this Request
Object that comes in.
I'm just going to do a
repeat for the name.
So if the name is A, it's going
to turn it into AA.
So I think times equals will
work for this, yes?
DAN HOLEVOET: I think
you're right.
DANNY HERMES: I'm just
going to try it.
So I'm calling request.name
times equals true.
As far as I know, it'll take
the string that's in
request.name and replace
it with string string
concatenated on top of itself.
Let's just see.
Great.
Go to sleep go to sleep.
Obviously, we don't
want to do that.
So before I actually go into
ways that you can store the
data, interact with the data
otherwise, I'm going to move
on and implement the
list method.
I don't know off the top my head
the path to the discovery
document, but I want to show you
guys this before I move on
to the list method.
So we've mentioned this a lot.
So this is actually creating a
discovery based API for you.
That's the reason this API's
explorer works, and the reason
our Android and Objective C
clients just work for you,
because they already know how to
take a discovery document,
consume it, and turn it into
the thing it needs to be
turned into.
So I believe this is the link.
Let's see, fingers crossed.
I might get give up.
DAN HOLEVOET: You could show
a public one as well if you
don't want to show
your local one.
DANNY HERMES: Yeah,
that's not as fun.
Yeah, it was the wrong link.
I just suck.
No, it was the right one.
I suck again.
No, you know what?
I went too far back
in the history.
It's V1 and we changed V1 to
vGDL for your benefit.
There we go.
It really doesn't exist.
But vGDL does exist.
There we go, our first 404.
We've got a 404.
So here's the discovery
document.
Now, it's just a JSON document,
but it's fairly
long, and it describes very nice
things that intelligent
clients can actually use.
So we've got simple
things, right?
We've got the name and the
version, tasks, vGDL, the
description.
But very quickly, we get some
more useful things.
So we have here schemas.
Schemas actually describe the
data so that things like what
we saw on the client, those drop
downs that know what it's
supposed to actually be sending,
can actually create
these drop downs.
And it's the same thing
when you have--
this is running in JavaScript,
so it's just like whatever you
want to do, do it.
But in strongly typed languages
like Java and
Objective C on Android, we're
actually able to use these
schemas and create strongly
typed classes
that you can call.
You don't have to write any of
the code to interact with
these things, right?
And of course, we also
have Resources.
Resources gives us a way to
actually figure out what the
API can do.
So we have this Resource Task
which I created, as I
mentioned, and it has
a bunch of methods.
Well for now, it just has one
method, but it will list more
and you can get listings
of other sub-resources.
So I just looked at the clock.
I'm going to implement
List Task.
Actually, first I need
to store them.
So I'm going to do it.
It'll be OK.
So I'm going to import ndb.
We're going to come up with a
simple model to actually store
the task itself, and we're going
to use ndb queries to
populate our list.
DAN HOLEVOET: And why are
we going to use ndb?
DANNY HERMES: We're going
to use ndb because
db is not as good.
There are two data store
APIs in Python.
One's called db, one's
called ndb.
The feature set of db is
completely contained in the
feature set of ndb.
And without really changing any
code at all, by switching
to ndb, you get caching
for free.
I've said this a lot on GDL,
but I'll say it some more--
DAN HOLEVOET: It's good
to repeat it.
DANNY HERMES: --and I'll
continue to say it some more.
So I'm just going to copy this
model pretty much verbatim--
excuse me, this message class.
And I'm going to create an ndb
model, and I'll just call it
task model.
So it's going to be a subclass
of ndb.model, and instead of
messages.StringField,
I'm going to use
ndb.StringProperty.
For those paying extra close
attention, you may have
noticed that I initially typed
StringProperty instead of
StringField.
Unlike with the protocol buffer
definitions, here, we
don't actually need the
index one and two.
So I'm going to use the same
field names, Name and Owner,
and I'm going to make
Name required again.
So all I'm going to do with this
task model is turn the
request into an instance
of task model.
So I'm going to set Name equal
to the name from the request.
I'm going to set Owner equal to
the owner from the request,
request.owner.
I have no sense for how close
this is to 80 characters,
because this font is so big.
And I'm just going to put
that in the data store.
So in this initial call to Task
Model, I'm creating a
model instance, and on the
instance, there's a put method
which just saves the object
in the data store.
So here, it's going to come in
handy that we have the Data
Store Viewer open in
the admin console.
So let me do a few of these.
So we've done this
for Go to Sleep.
Maybe we'll have Wake Up.
Who should wake up?
Definitely not me.
Can't say Dan H, because
that's both of us.
Did that execute?
There we go.
And so let me refresh
this guy.
If we go to the data store, we
can actually see the models
that we've inserted, and if we
were to play around more with
it, we could get more of them.
But we just want to do a query
and then peace out.
So let's actually implement
this other method.
So in the query case,
we actually don't
need an input request.
Actually no.
We're not going to use it.
So there's one, I can't remember
what it's called.
I think it's ProtoRPC
Message Types.
Let's see.
I believe, in
ProtoRPC.message_types, there
is a class called
Void Message.
And Void Message is for things
like a simple query like this
where you don't actually want to
send any information in the
query, you just want
information out in the response.
Now in reality, if you're doing
queries, you'd like to
allow paging, so you'd
want somebody to
give a token for paging.
You'd want to allow them
to limit the size.
And there's probably tons
of other things
you'd want to allow.
DAN HOLEVOET: Filters,
things like that.
DANNY HERMES: Filters,
et cetera.
But for this one, we're just
going to use Void Message.
And on the way out, we're going
to have a task list.
We're going to call
this task.list.
We'll leave it in the
Task resource.
Doesn't really matter, we can
put it in another resource.
It's doing the same things.
Instead of using the
path Task, we're
using the path Tasks.
Also, instead of POST,
we're using GET.
So actually, since we're using
different http verbs, we could
actually use the same path,
Task, for both, but it's not
very intuitive to have Task if
you're returning a list of
tasks, right?
So it actually turns out that
request won't be used because
it's going to be an instance
of Void Message.
And we're going to have to use
ndb here to actually query our
task model.
So this is about endpoints,
not ndb.
So if there are ndb things that
are not familiar, feel
free to ask them on our
Moderator queue or put them
other places.
But for now, I'm just
going to do it.
So there's a query method on
the model itself, and I can
just loop through all the
results in the query.
So for task in TaskModel.query,
I'm going to
save an instance of the
ProtoRPC Task Model
corresponding to what came
from the data store.
Now we can see you'd probably
like some nice methods to go
back and forth, and we're
actually going to talk about
this a bit next week.
But for now, we're just
going to do it the
old fashioned way.
So using this task, we're
going to append
an instance of Task.
Now, Task is the ProtoRPC class,
not the ndb class.
But we're going to actually use
the same values from the
task that we got from
the data store.
So Task, we're going to pass
Name, task.name, and Owner is
going to be task.owner.
And then we're going to return
an instance of TaskLists, and
for Items, we're just going to
give it our list of tasks.
DAN HOLEVOET: Sounds good.
DANNY HERMES: Fingers crossed?
DAN HOLEVOET: Fingers crossed.
DANNY HERMES: Let's see it.
So I'm going to reload the page,
which has all my methods
that I can use.
Nothing broke yet.
Going to go into
the List Method
now to actually execute.
And we've got a 200.
DAN HOLEVOET: Is the
content there?
DANNY HERMES: The content
is there.
DAN HOLEVOET: Perfect.
DANNY HERMES: It is not
pretty printed.
I actually know why it's
not pretty printed.
We should do this.
JSON.dumps, if you include
indent equals two,
it'll make it pretty.
This isn't so pretty.
But what it has, it has items
with a list with two elements.
The first is the task Go to
Sleep with no owner, and the
second, the less lazy
one of us, Dan--
it's actually not true
in real life--
owns the task Wake Up.
And you could, of course, go
ahead and insert something
else like Record this.
DAN HOLEVOET: Answer my email.
Schedule meetings.
DANNY HERMES: Mystery
GDL producer.
And then we go back, we ask for
a list, and hopefully, the
task records this for Mystery
GDL Producers in there.
There we go.
So I'm going to wrap this up.
We're going to be doing a fair
amount more of production
content, some live, some
not live for Endpoints.
But next week, I'm going to be
talking about another library
that you can use that I
personally wrote called
Endpoints Proto Data Store.
And from here, we're going to go
to the Moderator and try to
answer as many questions
as makes sense.
DAN HOLEVOET: Let's also put
in a plug for the public
documentation we have.
If you go to developers.googl
e.com/AppEngine, we have nice
Java and Python documentation
there for Endpoints.
If you follow our repositories
on GitHub, Google Cloud
Platform, we also have examples
of the Java and
Python back end in a simple tic
tac toe application, and
we have example clients for tic
tac toe for JavaScript,
iOS, and Android as well.
So those are pretty good places
to get started if you
want to see a little bit
more about this.
DANNY HERMES: Totally.
DAN HOLEVOET: All right, so
let's go to the questions.
Let me refresh these here.
We've got five.
Excellent.
So first one, how can I use
Google Endpoints code
generation via command line
tools like Maven or Gradle so
that release engineers and build
tools like Jenkins can
build and test Endpoints from
annotated source code.
So I think if I understand this
question correctly, it's
asking how you would integrate
some of the client library
generation, maybe discovery doc
generation that we do as
part of the SDK into the release
managements that you
might want to do with Maven.
So I believe--
and I'm not an expert with Maven
by any stretch of the
imagination--
but I believe you can run
command line scripts from
within a Maven command.
So all the things that you were
showing, if I were to
actually go and generate an
Android client library, an
Objective C client library, I
just run a command on the
command line.
We have equivalence in both
Python and Java for that.
I could create a rule that
says, build my back end.
When I'm done, generate this
command that will run based
off the JARs that I've
generated, give me my output
client library.
So it will totally work.
Maybe we needed some
examples on this.
I'm not exactly sure.
Maybe that's enough for people
to figure it out.
We'll see, I guess.
DANNY HERMES: In the Python
case, there's Endpoint cfg.py,
and it's in our wonderful
documentation,
which launched today.
And for those who want to use
it with integration and
testing, the source is open,
so you can just see the
methods which actually
correspond to the argument
parser and actually call those
directly, or somehow script
calling it yourself.
DAN HOLEVOET: Right.
And we have a .sh equivalent
for the Java side, too.
DANNY HERMES: Is it Endpoint
cfg.sh, or Endpoints.sh?
DAN HOLEVOET: I belive so.
I believe it's Endpoint cfg.sh
DANNY HERMES: Good enough.
So we have Endpoint cfg.sh and
.py for each of your poisons.
DAN HOLEVOET: Yes.
For people who like
to use Eclipse--
I'm sure there are some of
you-- we also have an
excellent integration in the
Google plug-in for Eclipse
that lets you really easily
generate client libraries
without having to touch the
command line at all.
So if you use Eclipse,
definitely do that.
It's way easier.
But if you're not an Eclipse
person or you prefer the
command line, we have great
tools for that stuff.
Next question.
Are Endpoints allowed to return
binary content, i.e. a
blobster item, or they
limited to text?
DANNY HERMES: So we only used
string here just for ease.
There are many types supported,
and we're working
on getting support
for all of them.
We currently support strings.
In Python, we support bytes,
but what happens on the
client, you're going to have a
URL safe base 64 version, and
that's what gets passed to the
server, and the server decides
whether or not those bytes are
good or not, whether or not
it's safe base 64.
And we support integers, both
32-bit and 64-bit, and we
support Booleans, we support
both floats and doubles.
You name it, we support it.
And we're working on getting
full support within Endpoints
for this to actually talk to
Google's API infrastructure.
DAN HOLEVOET: Right.
And in both the Python and Java
case, you can also nest
classes inside each other.
So if you want a more
complex hierarchy of
things, you can do that.
DANNY HERMES: As we saw
in Task List, right?
DAN HOLEVOET: Right.
DANNY HERMES: Wow.
We had a message field which
referenced the task, Message
Class, and you can--
turtles all the way down.
You can recurse it
all you like.
DAN HOLEVOET: Yes, exactly.
Next question.
If my JavaScript client code is
running within the same app
ID defining the endpoints and
using App Engine's user
service, are we automatically
authenticated to make requests
or do we need to do the
OAuth process anyway?
DANNY HERMES: You are not
automatically authenticated.
So the way the request comes
through API, it comes through
Google's API infrastructure
first, rather than to your
application directly.
So this note about same
application isn't necessarily
same application.
The sweet spot there isn't
necessarily your web app.
It's your web app and
your mobile apps.
So no, the cookie that you have
in the browser does not
actually come through with the
request, so you would need to
go through the OAuth
dance too.
But to have sort of a unified
experience with the way you're
treating users, it makes as much
sense to use OAuth in the
browser as it does
to use cookies.
And we'll be talking more about
OAuth at later dates.
But we've tried to make it as
easy as possible for launch,
but Auth is always
hard, right?
DAN HOLEVOET: As someone that
has spent a very large amount
of time dealing with OAuth one
and two, I can say that this
is actually, in my opinion, a
relatively amazingly simple
experience.
So we're looking forward to
showing you more about this.
DANNY HERMES: Click a
few buttons, cross
your fingers, right?
DAN HOLEVOET: Yeah.
DANNY HERMES: I could do Auth
right now if you want.
We'll wait.
DAN HOLEVOET: Let's save it.
Let's save it.
All right, next question.
I'd like to know if Unity
Endpoint is in your road map
in the short term?
DANNY HERMES: What is
Unity Endpoint?
DAN HOLEVOET: I'm not sure, but
that suggests to me that
it's not in our short
term roadmap.
DANNY HERMES: Probably.
DAN HOLEVOET: We can find out.
We can reply to the question
in Moderator.
DANNY HERMES: OK.
I'm going to Google it.
DAN HOLEVOET: All right.
Sounds good.
So that may be a
game framework.
DANNY HERMES: Unity is a game
framework, but the word
"unity" is pretty generic.
DAN HOLEVOET: Universal.
DANNY HERMES: I don't know.
We'll have to come
back to that one.
DAN HOLEVOET: We'll come
All right.
And the last question
has actually
been down-voted heavily.
It's sort of unrelated about
Excel of and Filemaker.
So let's just leave that one.
DANNY HERMES: Good deal.
DAN HOLEVOET: I think
we're done.
DANNY HERMES: All right.
Well, thanks everybody.
Join us again here same
time next week.
I'm going to be talking again
about Python Endpoints, but a
library called Endpoints
Proto Data Store.
And we will be announcing on
the Google Cloud Platform
Developers page, as well as
many other social media
channels, the other times
that we'll be talking.
DAN HOLEVOET: Great.
Sounds good.
Thank you.
DANNY HERMES: All right.